what do you make of death is this scary
I'm not looking forward to it but it
does not scare me
do you think about it
do you visualize it
I do
I do and
it's a beautiful visualization and a
beautiful dream when I go as part of the
food chain
it's not a good visualization when I go
is
part of a random act of violence in the
freaking drive-by or something because
the second
the the the accident
it
breaks a story that I believe has
already been written
at least I don't have the capacity yet
to to put it into a a a a a story a
Divine story
of the lives that we we live
and so there's something ugly and gross
about it
and it happens all the all the time uh
you know to to people all the time I
just feel like when it's part of the
food chain
when I go as part of the food Jam I'm
like Ah that's poetry part of the flow
of nature you return to Nature
yeah there's Grace and poetry in that